wir werden herr lauterbach am 21.12 die
schokolade im adventskalender haben
sondern bnt 162 b2 zulassung durch die
emea hat diese zeit zwei wochen
zusätzlich tatsächlich jetzt eine
gründlichere prüfung ermöglicht wissen
wir dass dieser impfstoff sicher ist wir
können davon ausgehen dass dieser
impfstoff sicher ist vor allen dingen
dem service sehr gut untersucht worden
also eben dem stoff ist mit dieser
methodik entwickelt worden über eine
sehr lange zeit und die untersuchung die
wir bisher gehabt haben die geben gut
anders zu glauben
unmittelbare früher nebenwirkungen die
sind ja quasi ausgeschlossen
das hat keine schweren zwischenfälle bei
ungefähr 20.000 patienten gegeben die
den impfstoff genommen haben und schwere
impfstoff nebenwirkungen kommen in der
regel relativ früh somit wurde ich
selbst den impfstoff also ohne zu zögern
auch nehmen ich würde selbst nutzen ich
halte neben stoff für sicher und die
prüfung durch die europäische
arzneimittelbehörde ist gründlich
gewesen aber das waren auch schon die
prüfungen durch die vor den toiletten
historischen in den vereinigten staaten
und das sehr rigorose verfahren in
england und sie sagen nach wie vor diese
verzögerung diese zwei wochen haben
menschenleben gekostet hat naja wenn der
impfstoff hierzu einmal in
pflegeeinrichtungen früher zur verfügung
gestanden hätte dann hätte dadurch der
ein oder andere den impfstoff bekommen
wir so noch also sich infiziert hat
somit das kann man jetzt nicht
ausrichten aber wahrscheinlich ist das
so aber ich blicke immer noch vorne und
wir haben jetzt die zulassung oder wie
bekommen sie haben 21
und dann wird der eben stoff breit
benutzt und wir sind bei tobias ans dem
ministerpräsidenten des saarlandes 127
zwölfter jetzt erster impftermin das hat
sicherlich symbolwirkung dass das noch
in diesem jahr geschieht aber für 99
prozent der menschen in diesem land wird
sich erstmal nichts ändern oder das ist
ja völlig klar dass wir zuerst
diejenigen impfen werden die ganz
besonders betroffen sind menschen die
besonders verletzlich sind durch das
virus das versteht auch jeder und wir
konnten ja auch keinen tag jetzt
verspielen egal ob das jetzt zwischen
den tagen ist wie man sagt nach
weihnachten geht es los ich finde das
ist
ein gutes signal an das wird uns helfen
nach all unseren erfahrungen mit den
masken und mit den tests sind denn genug
spritzen da muss man fragen also das
haben die länder glaube ich organisiert
wir haben im saarland sichergestellt
dass schon ganz früh zeitig genügend
verbrauchsmaterialien da waren ich habe
mich selbst davon überzeugt gestern
es steht alles bereit und es ist sehr
gut organisiert die menschen in
deutschland können darauf vertrauen dass
das impfen in den impfzentren
hervorragend organisiert ablaufen wird
und vor allem sicher christiane woopen
ist bei uns chefin des europäischen
ethikrates frau wuppen verrate kein
geheimnis die menschen die hier am tisch
sitzen sind alle unter 60 wann dürfen
wir damit rechnen wir uns zu sein
weihnachten nächstes jahr große sind
darauf an ob wir eine vorerkrankung
haben das geht ja nicht nur nach alters
geht ja auch nach vorerkrankungen und
auch zum teil nach sozialen erwägungen
wobei wir die wir jetzt am tisch sitzen
nicht zu den sozial benachteiligten
gehören die nach meiner meinung nach der
meinung des europäischen ethikrates auch
bevorzugt werden sollten weil sich ja
soziale ungleichheit durch die pandemie
auch noch einmal verschärfen statt und
da kann man auch das impfen einsetzen um
solche ungleichheiten auszugleichen und
abzuschwächen
aber ich denke so rundherum werden wir
als letzte dran kommt und je nachdem wie
schnell dann auf weitere impfstoffe
zugelassen werden also für von moderner
das ist ja jetzt auch schon von der
europäischen arzneimittelbehörde für
sehr bald angesagt dann kann es
vielleicht schneller gehen
und wenn dann auch noch so etwas wie der
patentschutz ausgesetzt wird und dass
tatsächlich vielleicht sogar zu einem
globalen zu einem öffentlichen gemeingut
wird dann geht es noch schneller und das
auch im globalen maßstab und nicht nur
in deutschland nicht nur in deutschland
und nicht nur in europa jonas schmidt
chanasit ist bei uns bernhard nocht
institut hamburg immer gern gesehener
gast das ist in diesem jahr tatsächlich
an vielen stellen der fall gewesen dass
wir uns häufig sagen und auf ihre
expertise bauen konnten
diese großen versprechen wir hatten
schon ein paar davon
die tests sollten game changer seien die
app sollte game changer sein ist es gut
jetzt schon wieder so viel erwartungen
zu wecken in bezug auf eine
massenimpfung
die fakten die vorgetragen wurden die
teile ich vollkommen und man muss mal
deutlich betont ich bin selber sehr sehr
überrascht gewesen dass das so
erfolgreich so schnell alles
durchgegangen ist als hätte ich wie
gesagt vor einigen monaten nie für
möglich gehalten dass das ende diesen
jahres quasi einsatzbereit bereit steht
und die ersten games werden können und
ich kann das eigentlich nur sozusagen
bestätigen was die kollegen hast gesagt
haben ich etwas worauf wir hoffen
sollten und ja es ist ein ganz wichtiger
baustein
das will ich auch noch mal betonen wir
dürfen das andere nicht vernachlässigen
das ist klar aber es wurde sehr sehr
großer aufwand betrieben haben im
zentrum gesprochen
wir haben die anderen kollegen
ärztlichen kollegen die sich jetzt
engagieren damit die impfung
durchgeführt werden können auch
niedergelassene bereich hoffentlich wenn
es denn die impfstoffe dann auch zu
lassen also das ist schon eine mammut
aufgabe gewesen die nach all dem was wir
wissen gut bewältigt wurde und schützt
nun diese impfung nur den der sie
bekommt oder verhindert sie auch dass es
eine ausbreitung gibt und ansteckung
stattfindet nach all dem was wir jetzt
vom montag im stoff wissen ist es
erstmal so dass krankheit verhindert
wird es gibt hinweise darauf dass auch
letztendlich eine übertragung verhindert
werden könnte bei moderner impfstoff
wahrscheinlich noch etwas mehr daten
dazu aber es ist es ist auch erst mal
gar nicht glaube ich die entscheidende
frage man muss das auch noch mal
deutlich unterscheiden das ist doch
schon mal ein großer schritt nach vorne
wenn wir die die ein besonders hohes
risiko haben zu versterben wenn wir die
davor schützen können und der zweite
schritt und da kommt genau die globale
rechtlich gerechtigkeit ins spiel wäre
dann die so genannte herdenimmunität
oder eine immunitätsregelung der
bevölkerung zu zeigen was eine ganz
andere
ein ganz anderes ziel ist es eine
riesige herausforderung ist weil die
menschen mitmachen müssen insofern wenn
ich da ganz auf der seite von frau wir
sollten europäischen natürlich denken
darum finde ich das auch hervorragend
dass das so gedacht wurde
und natürlich auch an die länder die
sich diesen impfstoff erst mal nicht
leisten werden können also wir hatten
noch mal fest es wird haben wir schon
viel besprochen nicht nur den einen
impfstoff geben es sind wenigstens drei
absehbar am start vielleicht sogar noch
mehr und man muss natürlich sehr genau
wissen was die am ende
und wofür und für wen sie sich besonders
eignen
herr lauterbach überrascht ist sie
eigentlich dass die impfbereitschaft in
deutschland gar nicht so groß ist wie
gedacht und gerade auch medizinisches
personal da sehr zurückhaltend ist ja
aber ich ganz ehrlich sagen das
überrascht mich denn also die krankheit
ist ja also in ihrem verlauf bekannt
dass es gefährlich für jeden also das
bekommt und das kann alter
ausgeschlossen da hätte ich gerade
meinen kolleginnen und kollegen höheren
bereitschaft erwartet ich glaube dass
das noch kommen wird wir werden ja neben
kampagne auch machen wo wir aufklären
also wir versuchen zu überzeugen und
also es gibt jetzt sogar auch hinweise
also jetzt erst den wassers in den
studien bisher nicht untersucht worden
aber es gibt auch hinweise darauf dass
die impfstoffe so stark wirken dass sie
besser schützen also eine leichte
durchgemachte infektion und
wahrscheinlich also dass es noch nicht
untersucht aber bei moderner gibt es da
auch studien mäßig hinweise wird die
impfung auch vor ansteckung und wenn man
sich ansteckt sehr wahrscheinlich
zumindest dann vor der weitergabe der
erkrankung schützen somit hat es eine
massive bedeutung und ich verstehe da
die zurückhaltung der kolleginnen und
kollegen noch nicht gehen aber ganz
sicher dass sich das ändern lässt sich
das ändert und wir wissen ja eben wie
sie schon sagen bald auch noch viel mehr
über die möglichen nebenwirkungen
respektive die nicht vorhandenen
nebenwirkungen
jetzt sagt herr hans der csu
generalsekretär dass das impfen zu einer
patriotischen pflicht werden müsste
stellen wir uns das vor denkt der mensch
da er an seine gesundheit oder denkt er
an deutschland was glauben sie kann so
für mich ist es vor allem ein akt der
solidarität dass auch junge menschen
sagen selbstverständlich lasse ich mich
impfen dann wenn ich an der reihe bin
für mich ist es völlig klar dass ich das
tun werde wenn der impfstoff verfügbar
ist schütze mg schütze meine
allernächsten und ich schütze
selbstverständlich auch ältere menschen
kranke menschen damit dass ich das tue
und jede bürgerin und jeder bürger
sollte sich fragen ob sie das nicht
vielleicht auch den menschen schuldig
ist die auf den intensivstationen
tagtäglich ihre arbeit tun also ich
halte das nicht für eine patriotische
pflicht in dem sinne aber ich halte es
für eine
solidarische leistung der bevölkerung
und ich glaube wir kriegen das in
deutschland hin zumal doch für alle ist
einfach eine schöne sache ist dass
deutsche forscher innen auch daran
mitgewirkt haben dass dieser impfstoff
entwickelt worden ist also mich macht
das stolz wenn ich sehe dass gerade der
biontech impfstoff ganz nah von mir
entwickelt worden ist sogar von personen
die im saarland geforscht haben ich
finde das gut und man daher darf das
schon gesehen stolz machen aber
letztendlich muss jeder selbst dazu weiß
darüber sind frau wuppen menschen suchen
vorbilder wir haben kampagne schon
angesprochen müssen sich jetzt dann
tatsächlich irgendwie auch politiker
möglichst schnell impfen lassen um zu
sagen freunde wie karl lauterbach habt
keine sorgen es ist was gutes tut es
soll ja die politiker dann dran sind
nach der risiko groß für mich aber man
kann ja auch die kampagne als einen
grund nehmen durchaus da auch beim
menschen vorzuziehen die vielleicht noch
nicht genau in diese gruppe gehören aber
es gab ja dieses interessante beispiel
mit der angelina jolie bei dem erblichen
brust- und eierstockkrebs da haben sich
tausende onkologen jahre lang den mund
fusselig geredet um die frauen zu
erreichen die vielleicht in einer
solchen risiko konstellation sind und
dann schreibt angelina jolie einen
beitrag oder lädt einmal in die
öffentlichkeit und die ganzen zentren
können sich nicht mehr retten
voranmeldungen
also wenn wir jetzt mal die richtigen
personen finden die viele menschen
erreichen und das müssen gar keine
politiker und auch gar keine
wissenschaftler seien die kommen aus
völlig anderen branchen wieder wirklich
die emotionen der menschen erreichen
denken an angelina jolie und an helene
fischer oder was weiß ich genau an
aber was mich sehr interessieren würde
ist wie lange denn eigentlich diese
immunität dann anhält denn das ist ja
entscheidend dafür wann dann auch die
menschen die jetzt am anfang geimpft
wurden dann wieder geimpft werden muss
das werde dann noch in zu 100 prozent
genau herr schmidt chanasit halbes jahr
dreivierteljahr wer von ihnen beiden
möchte kann er dort war das geht in die
richtung aber das ist eine ganz
entscheidende frage weil die frage ist
ob wir natürlich also welche impfstoffe
dann verfügbar sein könnten und wie dann
genau das im film aussehen würde wenn
der schutz rein spekulativ eben nicht
mehr
da wäre war da wäre ich eben sehr
vorsichtig da schon jetzt zu viel zu
spekulieren
aber es gibt also ein paar gute
nachrichten hier ich mir ja
normalerweise der überbringer er der
schwierigen nachrichten daher bin ich
immer dankbar wenn ich etwas positives
sagen aber aus damit sie also zu machen
hat sich gezeigt also an der wichtigen
studie des scripps institute in la jolla
in den vereinigten staaten das die
antikörper immunität und auch die also
gedächtniszellen immunität hier lange
anhält also nicht bei geimpften sondern
bei diejenigen die schon erkrankt war
und da dieser messenger rna im stoff
sich sehr gut eignet wiederholt genutzt
zu werden
das besser als vektor impfstoffe wo man
dann oft eine immunität gegen den vektor
aufbaut somit wiederholte impfungen dort
problematisch sind glaube ich
tatsächlich dass wir hier eine sehr gute
straße erwischt haben wo eine also
immunität meinetwegen das kann man jetzt
nur abschätzen aber über ein jahr zum
beispiel erreicht wird und wo man mit
dem impfen mit dem booster impfstoff
dann noch erneut nachsetzen kann ohne
die immunität also über die zeit zu
verlieren das ist schon also sehr
erfolgreichen finde ich und jetzt gibt
es einen bundesgesundheitsminister der
sich schon ausmalt wann wir eigentlich
stichwort dann diese herdenimmunität
erreicht hätten und die runde drehen wir
dazu noch stand heute 15 12 da dürfen
wir erwarten dass wir im sommer genug
impfstoff haben für alle die sich impfen
lassen wollen aber wir können ihn
begründet auch sagen zuversichtlich auch
sagen ab dem sommer können wir zug um
zug in die normalität zurückkehren das
ist natürlich hochinteressant schmidt
chanasit
ab dem sommer zug um zug in die
normalität zurück wenn der chef der
stiko der ständigen impfkommission sagt
wir brauchen für das impfen wenigstens
bis 2022
also wenigstens ein jahr kann man dann
für die mitte des nächsten jahres
ankündigen dass wir dann in die
normalität zurückkehren ja das war jetzt
wenig konkret das war nur eine aussage
bezüglich der menge der der impfdosen
die verfügbar sind wie gesagt auch der
minister kann natürlich nicht die
glaskugel gucken und weiß jetzt genau
wie viel sich jetzt wirklich waren
impfen lassen werden
gut sich das auch umsetzen dass das ist
glaube ich wenn alles extrem gut läuft
ist das durchaus machbar aber ich denke
wenn so wie er uns das gesagt hat wenn
man jetzt wirklich realistisch rangeht
hat man glaube ich wirklich einen
längeren zeithorizont aber man weiß es
nicht weil auch hier spielt wieder das
verhaltene bevölkerung wie auch bei
allen anderen maßnahmen eine
entscheidende rolle
und das was frau open auch immer betont
genau quasi das was sie mit angelina
jolie gesagt haben vertrauen ist ganz
entscheidend da sie überzeugt werden und
wenn dann ist quasi so ein booster gibt
dann kann es sein dass das blitzschnell
geht und dann wirklich das im sommer
passiert ist und man dann eben sieht ok
man kann bei bestimmten maßnahmen eben
wieder ein normales niveau erreichen
wenn das weniger gut funktioniert dann
ist es eben 2022
und man muss aber immer wieder sagen die
masken können dann erst ab herr
lauterbach wenn wir diese jeden
immunität erreicht haben ja und selbst
sagen also zunächst einmal wenn
herdenimmunität erreicht wird dann
bedeutet das nicht dass die infektion
weg ist das bedeutet nur dass die sagen
wir 30 prozent in der bevölkerung die
dann noch nicht also infiziert waren
dass die sich langsamer infizieren aber
sie sind irgendwann dann auch dran von
daher also ist tatsächlich das
problematisch ich kann auch wenn ich die
herdenimmunität fast erreicht habe auf
masken und abstände nicht verzichten
will ich die anderen auch schützen weil
das ist nicht also man denkt dann das
sind 60 70 prozent erreicht die anderen
kommentar nicht gekommen dann langsamer
daran uns zum zweiten also die aussage
von gesundheitsminister sparen wäre dann
also zuverlässig oder wer haltbar wenn
der asta oxford impfstoff zugelassen
wird und wenn sich bestätigt dass die
wirksamkeit hat in der niedrig dosierten
form es gibt da zwei unterschiedliche
wirksam karten und ob die hohe
wirksamkeit bei der niedrig dosierten
vorn wirklich gilt das wissen wir nicht
wahr dann der studie waren nur unter 55
jährige wenn das sich nicht bestätigt
dann halte ich es nicht für darstellbar
dass wir im sommer jedem der sich impfen
lassen möchte den impfstoff anbieten
können das war ja die aussage wenn ich
es richtig verstanden habe und also das
ist nur haltbar unter zwei
voraussetzungen das sagen wir der hui ho
das amt hat die 90% wirksamkeit beim
asta impfstoff sich bei der neuen studie
das wird jetzt noch einmal neu getestet
dass ich das bestätigt wie gesagt das
kann man nicht sagen weil er war nur
unter 55 jährige drin und der impfstoff
schnell zugelassen wird war sonst haben
wir nicht nennen
mit moderner und bei und tag würden wir
das nicht schaffen und der sanofi ihren
stoff hat große probleme kommt nicht das
heißt das hängt davon ab wie gut der
asta impfstoff ist unter bekommt und ob
er kommt damit wir allein auf die
quantität wachsen sonst haben wir das
volumen der hans auch eine entscheidende
frage wenn wir bis zum sommer diese
herdenimmunität nicht schaffen wir jetzt
noch mal sagen was machen wir eigentlich
in der zeit bis dahin wenn wir sie bis
zum sommer nicht schaffen muss man dann
doch über eine impfpflicht nachdenken
also ich halte das für völlig falsch
jetzt von der impfpflicht zu reden das
macht den menschen angst und es sind
eingriffe in die unversehrtheit
das sollten wir nicht tun wir müssen auf
freiwilligkeit setzen und vertrauen
schaffen dass die menschen an diesen
impfstoff glauben und das ist jetzt das
alles entscheidende und man sollte auch
keine falschen versprechungen machen
wann irgendeiner durchimpfung erreicht
ist wir müssen loslegen und beginnen zu
impfen erlebt haben was du den jungen
sagen sie sagten eben dass die jungen
das aus solidarischen gründen für die
älteren auch machen aber die jungen
müsste es eigentlich auch für sich
selber für ihre eigene generation machen
denn ich würde da gar nicht mehr diesen
generationen
dieses generation narrativ aufmachen
wollen
denn jeder junge mensch kennt auch
irgendjemand einen anderen jungen
menschen mit einer vorerkrankung der ein
besonders hohes risiko hatte ich meine
das was vom gemeinsamen bundesausschuss
als risikogruppe definiert worden ist
umfasst ja ein drittel der bevölkerung
und da sind nicht nur alte menschen drin
und insofern ist es wichtig zu sagen das
müssen die jungen auch füreinander
untereinander tun und nicht nur für die
älteren tatsächlich wir können ja gar
nicht unsere vorerkrankung alles hat ja
nicht jeder einen perfekten
medizinischen status von seinem körper
wissen wie hoch eigentlich sein
persönliches risiko ist also noch mal
wir tun es klugerweise nicht nur für uns
wir tun es sowieso für die anderen aber
auch für uns und egal in welchem alter
wir sind schauen wir zurück ganz kurz
wie wir eigentlich in diese situation
gekommen sind in der wir jetzt sind
liebe zuschauer eigentlich wollte ihn
überhaupt keiner und jetzt wollten ihn
dann irgendwie alle den harten shutdown
nämlich
[Musik]
aus vorbei
alles dicht deutschland hat ausgetanzt
[Musik]
nach neun monaten sind wir wieder da wo
wir am anfang der pandemie waren dabei
glaubten viele inzwischen viel mehr zu
wissen man würde mit dem wissen heute
keine friseure mehr schließen und keinen
einzelhandel mehr schließen
das wird nicht noch einmal passieren
sie waren es die der kanzlerin auf der
nase rumtanzen um jede einzelne
schließung wurde stundenlang gerungen
ausknipsen oder nicht selbst als merkel
ende september das jahresend szenario
durchgerechnet hat
und wenn das in den nächsten drei
monaten oktober november dezember weiter
so wäre dann würden wir von 2400 auf
4800 auf 9.600 auf 19.200 kommen
erst ende oktober kommt der
vermeintliche befreiungsschlag
deutschland will wieder musterschüler
seien mit einem raffinierten
wellenbrecher lockdown leid corona
hardliner und soft dies jubilieren und
wir haben jetzt quasi wie im lehrbuch
kann man sagen beim aufsteigenden ast
also des exponentiellen wachstums haben
wir sehr früh sehr konsequent gehandelt
weil wir auch den bürgerinnen und
bürgern versprechen können diese
maßnahmen sind befristet sie gelten bis
ende november
es scheint kurzfristig hat ist aber
langfristig milder als die alternativen
nichts zu tun und dann eine
endlosschleife uns mit dem thema zu
beschäftigen und das ganze land leiden
zu lassen
heute wissen wir wir sind in einer
endlosschleife
wie es anfang januar weitergeht können
wir heute noch nicht sagen da ist auch
die kanzlerin noch zitiert zehnter
januar wie es danach eigentlich nach dem
zehnten weitergeht wissen wir nicht wir
haben sie zitiert herr hans mit dem
bemerken dass bis wir bei 50 auf 100000
incidents sind vorher können wir von
diesem shutdown nicht unterwanderte sein
ist dass ostern oder ist es im mai oder
was denken sie also erstmal muss man
noch mal erklären warum 50 auf 100.000
in der woche das hat was mit kontakt
nachverfolgung zu tun
das war unser ziel immer dass kontakte
nachverfolgt werden können
50 ist das minimum das wir erreichen
müssen besser natürlich 35 das weiß
jeder
und es ist einfach eine frage der
moderation wenn ich mir anschaue was die
wissenschaftler innen jetzt sagen und
dann sehen wir bei einem mehrwert wie
wir im moment haben der über 1 ist bei
neuinfektionen wie wir sie im moment
haben kann das vor mitte januar kaum der
fall sein und das jetzt schon voraus
dass es an weihnachten nicht zu einem
starken anstieg der infektionszahlen
kommt was ich heute auch so klar noch
nicht sehe und deswegen sehe ich gar
keine chance dass man zum zehnten januar
aus dem block dauern wir jetzt ist noch
mal raus kommt es wird länger dauern
geht das versagen in der zweiten welle
auf die kappe der ministerpräsidenten
die bundeskanzlerin hat viel früher eine
härtere kontakt beschränkungen gefordert
also wir alle haben unsere
verfassungsgerichts höfe in den ländern
und wir alle sind auch gehalten aufgrund
der entscheidungen der parlamente immer
das mildere mittel zu ergreifen das
haben wir versucht mit diesem teil
lockdown man muss aber ganz klar sagen
es hat nicht funktioniert detail
lockdown hat nicht so gewirkt wie er
sollte im saarland ist eine zeitlang
tatsächlich die infektions kurve nach
unten gegangen dann wieder
seitwärtsbewegung dann steigende zahlen
man muss es ganz klar sagen das hat
nicht zum erfolg geführt und deswegen
müssen wir jetzt scharfe massnahmen
ergreifen wir wollten immer frau wurden
vermeiden dass wir
in einer bergamo situation kommen dass
wir eine triage erwägen müssen das ist
jetzt in sachsen in brandenburg
heidelberg baden-württemberg der fall
wie konnte das passieren dass wir
ausgerechnet die weltmeister der
pandemie die bearbeitung in einer
situation landen wo wir das wichtigste
ziel aus den augen verloren haben
nämlich trias vermeiden überforderung
vermeiden
ich glaube daran sind eigentlich alle
beteiligt und das ist jetzt auch nicht
unbedingt eine schuldzuweisung außer
vielleicht an diejenigen die sich ganz
ausdrücklich und bewusst gegen die
regeln verhalten und auch nicht bereit
sind sich irgendwie eine
auseinandersetzung einer vernunft
basierten auseinandersetzung zu stellen
ich glaube dass wir aber auch zur
vorbereitung der situation das eine oder
andere noch nicht ausreichend getan
haben also beispielsweise auch für diese
situation jetzt parlamentarischen triage
gesetz auf den weg zu bringen ich weiß
dass das ein sehr umstrittenes thema ist
ich gehöre zu denjenigen die sagen dass
der bundestag die aufgabe hat so
wesentliche dinge zu regeln wie die
zuteilung von lebenschancen
ja und es ihm das nicht den ärzten zu
überlassen sondern muss nicht den ärzten
oder vereinigungen zu überlassen die
dafür gar kein gesetzliches mandat haben
und mir ist noch kein gesicht kein
argument untergekommen
das mich davon überzeugt hatte dass der
bundestag dafür nicht in der
verantwortung steht aber so traurig das
ist dass jetzt diese situation an
manchen orten tatsächlich schon droht
oder so ich meine die berichterstattung
darüber ist ja auch ein bisschen vage
also ich würde das glaube ich gar nicht
so formulieren dass es da schon so ist
sondern das sind mehr so warnungen wir
stehen kurz davor oder es fühlt sich
schon so an als sei das so in der tat
werden schon patienten verlegt etc
also legen es ist eine drohende szenario
zumindest mal aber ich finde so
großartig wenn wir diesen lockdown jetzt
mal für etwas anderes nutzen könnten
nämlich für einen massentest ja denn das
hat sich an unterschiedlichen stellen
gezeigt dass die kombination von lock
down und massentest zu einer halbierung
oder ein liverpool sogar zu 75 prozent
niedrigeren infektionszahlen führen
das heißt wir könnten diesen lockdown
dadurch erheblich verkürzen und die zeit
dann auch nutzen eben um für die zeit
danach die maßnahmen so aufzustellen
dass wir nicht in die dritte welle
reinlaufen denn so schnell kommt ja die
warme jahreszeit nicht wieder dass wir
uns wieder für auf verhältnisse wie im
letzten sommer freuen können wir merken
uns dass und trotzdem ist es ganz
wichtig noch mal kurz die kurve zu
drehen herr lauterbach wir haben sie
auch zitiert wir dachten sie dachten
genau wie so viele hofften dass diese
wellenbrecher lockdown leid uns helfen
würde und dass er auch nach vier wochen
enden würde und dass die politik den
menschen dann weihnachten schenken
könnte warum hat es nicht funktioniert
aus drei gründen also ich war ja damals
an der entwicklung beteiligt und die
wissenschaftler die das versucht haben
zu modellieren
die haben damals schon an punkt also
sagen wir sehr kontrovers diskutiert und
zwar ob das möglich ist einen solchen
circuit breaker durchzuführen wenn man
gleichzeitig die betriebe und die
schulen offen lässt oder ob man eines
von wahlen schließen muss und damals war
ich zum beispiel der meinung dass man
das riskieren kann
es gab aber auch in der gruppe michael
herrmann zum beispiel der gesagt hat das
geht nicht die schulen sind also zu
wichtig als infektionsherd die müssen
geschlossen werden
das war offen das haben wir aber auch
kommuniziert also wir haben in der runde
auch mit der bundeskanzlerin und mit
andern haben wir klar kommuniziert das
können wir nicht wirklich auflösen dass
der erste grund da war eine unsicherheit
in der zweite grund ist danach wurde
sofort wieder über lockerungen
gesprochen also kaum hatten wir das
gemacht dieses hotels offen an
weihnachten
es wurde plötzlich die innenstädte
gerettet also verkaufsoffene sonntage
wochen debattiert black friday und so
weiter und so fort als es wurde so
fordernde lockerungs debatten war so
dass die menschen das falsche signal
bekannt und dann sind die menschen auch
nicht mehr bereit gewesen somit zu
ziehen wie vorher es gab glühweinstände
bratwurststände die innenstädte bahn
flotte hatten einfach nicht mehr die
bereitschaft mitzuziehen
somit ist fehlte also an einem klaren
konzept muss man offen sagen es hat sich
über uns nachher die studien sind quasi
die waren damals als pre prinz schon da
heute seine studie in nature von der
harvard und von oxford und wie
wesentlichen anderen universitäten
entschieden die haben belegen ganz klar
dass man die schulen wenn man so an
startern machen muss mit schließen muss
die schulen und die unis tisch holen und
die uns das war damals im pre print noch
nicht die revolution da war wohl richtig
gestellt ich dachte das kann gehen
andere dachten nicht aber es war
tatsächlich und jetzt er was sich das
aber sehr klar da haben diejenigen recht
gehabt die gesagt haben
kinder und jugendliche sind wesentliche
muss man sagen
treiber der pandemie leider in den
vorstudien ich will es nur noch mal
übersetzen also in diesem previews in
den vorabdrucken der studien und
christian drosten bei derjenige der
darauf aufmerksam gemacht hat dass man
nicht unterschätzen sollten sich er war
daran auch beteiligt er hat das ja auch
mitgetragen aber wir haben diese wir
haben waren wir waren da sehr offen
auch untereinander wir haben das sehr
offen aufgetan wir haben auch
untereinander jeweils also uns
gegenseitig also somit mit respekt also
gesagt das können wir nicht wirklich auf
lesen die studienlage ist nicht klagen
so und dann sind sie natürlich bei der
frage dass wir jetzt in diesem harten
shutdown sind herr schmidt chanasit ist
es die schuld der bürger oder ist es
tatsächlich eine situation die durch
alle entstanden ist durch falsche
einschätzung in der politik und auch die
menschen die am liebsten im rhein stand
es bringt jetzt nichts die schuldigen
bürgern in die schuhe zu schieben dass
wir alle nicht weiter klar ist das
wasser laut aber auch gesagt hat das
muss gelingen die bürger einzubinden und
sie letztendlich zu begeistern für die
maßnahmen wenn das gelingt dann sind
diese maßnahme erfolgreich und wenn das
nicht gelingt dann nützen auch die
besten maßnahmen ist sondern das
betrifft auch die schulen damit nur
sagen dass ich diese ergebnisse auch
anders interpretieren etwas vorsichtig
wenn ich ganz so eindeutig aber das ist
auch okay es ist nach wie vor glaube ich
kein einfaches thema wir müssen die alte
altersgruppen unterscheiden wir müssen
sozusagen unterscheiden ob die eltern
dann auch nach hause gehen das sind
sozusagen andere effekte die auch auch
mit reinspielen das wird dann sehr
detailliert und die schulen sind ja
wirklich ein großes thema was auch
viele probleme auslösen kann ich habe
auch gerade noch mal mit bürgermeister
tschentscher gesprochen zum beispiel die
haben ja betriebe die ganz relevant sind
für die test herstellung oder so haben
wir das material und die sind ganz stark
darauf angewiesen dass zum beispiel
mitarbeiter die kinder weiter in die
kita schicken können das ist darum ist
dieser notbetrieb dass meine städtischen
betreuung war ja nie in der diskussion
ja ich glaube in einigen bundesländern
ist es ein bisschen vielleicht ein
bisschen stärker ausgeprägt als in
anderen es gibt ja diese unterschiede
zwischen den bundesländern weil ich sage
nochmal das ist eben nicht ganz so
einfach auch nicht ob herr lauterbach
hatte auch gesagt ob man jetzt das so
schnell schießt du da nicht gerade in
dem bereich gibt es viele diskussionen
aber nochmal zurück zum thema wichtig
ist dass man in die bevölkerung hinein
wirken kann
und da können wir wirklich von anderen
ländern lernen die durch evaluiert
wurden wie das geschehen kann das ist
sehr aufwendig das ist eben genau das
engagement und das muss letztendlich
professionalisiert wenn das muss
unterstützt wenn es ist eine
mammutaufgabe
aber wenn wir leute haben die über teste
auflagen die auch professionell testen
durchführen können die masken verteilen
die den leuten helfen ja und wir
verwenden jetzt viele milliarden um
genau eben diese maßnahmen die warten
theaterschließungen restaurant
schließung das zu ermöglichen
es ist ja letztendlich die frage wir
haben begrenzte mittel und an welchen
punkten kann man die sehr gut einsetzen
um eine große wirksamkeit zu erreichen
genau die ziele die wir haben dass die
zahl nach unten gehen dass keine
überlastung stattfindet und genau diese
diskussion glaube ich müsste man führen
und führen wird auch offen und da sehe
ich eben dem punkt dass man vielleicht
dieses geld eher in diese richtung hätte
gut investieren können haben die
menschen lieber zu überzeugen als jetzt
den schatten zu bezahlangeboten es geht
nicht um überzeugen oder sozusagen
appellieren es geht wirklich um konkrete
das was wir auch in tübingen das was für
ein tübingen sehen dass sozusagen in die
bevölkerung hinein tragen diese breite
wirkung was die risikogruppen anbetrifft
aber was auch die angehörigen der
risikogruppen betrifft ja wir bringen
gibt es das jetzt auch schon ziemlich
viele verstorbene in altenpflege
einrichtung also es war ja auch nicht
jetzt ein paar erfolgreich unterm strich
noch mal wir schalten das machen wir
bevor wir
der runde kurz den gedanken von truppen
aufnehmen herr hans wäre das ein guter
zeitpunkt um etwas was wir schon lange
diskutieren nämlich uns mit test
sicherer zu machen
ausnutzen und einem massentest in
deutschland machen um den leuten sofort
zusagen in quarantäne die nächsten
sieben tage dann ist das ja auch einfach
jeder weiß sofort ob er infiziert ist
oder nicht und kann in selbst quarantäne
gehen und wir würden aus dieser not
heraus kommen die gesundheitsämter damit
zu befassen so viele tests sind immer
gut das haben wir von anfang an gesagt
und am besten auch tatsächlich in der
breite der bevölkerung man muss eben
auch nur wissen nach wie vor sind die
kapazitäten begrenzt von tests und vor
allem auch der menschen die die tests
durchführen stimmten das ist das problem
vor dem wir nach wie vor stehen und auch
wenn man sich jetzt anschaut was aus
meiner sicht gut gemacht wird auch in
baden württemberg was massen testen
angeht so sind es doch vergleichsweise
sehr wenige tests die zur verfügung
stehen wenn ich richtig informiert bin
80.000 tests die dort zur verfügung
stehen für ein bundesland baden
württemberg das ist nicht sehr viel
deswegen darf man da auch nicht den
anschein erwecken dass man wirklich alle
durch testen kann
und im übrigen muss man ja auch noch mal
sagen ein test ist ja zunächst einmal
nur ein navigationssystem das heißt ich
sehe wie viele menschen sind infiziert
aber es hält nicht davon ab dass man
andere infiziert das schafft im moment
nur abstand und hygienemaßnahmen
menschen könnten in selbst quarantäne
gehen frau gruppen hat massiv den kopf
gestellt zu sagen es sind mehr tests da
wir müssen jetzt auch sagen über welche
wir reden genau nicht die pcr test
sondern die antiken test diese
schnelltests genau es kommt ja vor allen
dingen auf den nachweis an ob man
infektiös ist ob ein anderer anstecken
kann nicht unbedingt ob man selber
infiziert ist das ist ja auch noch mal
ein unterschied und von den anti gen
tests gibt es genau ich habe mich
gestern bei roche noch mal schlau
gemacht
das kann roche alleine nicht stemmen
aber das könnten mit anderen herstellern
siemens und vielen kleinen start-ups et
cetera kann das gestemmt werden bei den
fce gibt es von einem mbit test jemand
zu hause machen kann gestern die erste
notfall zulassung quasi da kann man das
über eine digitale an
sogar selber machen also über
dezember/januar würden wir es mit einer
politischen kraftanstrengungen
hingekommen alle menschen in diesem land
einmal durch zu testen man könnte die
heimat bringt das man einmal aus die
sagt also einmal diese infektiosität
halbiert oder vielleicht sogar noch mehr
man könnte beispielsweise soja aber
derjenige der geht ja dann erst mal in
die quarantäne
idealerweise ja also die hoffentlich
würden dass dann die meisten tun
und die würden schon mal keine anderen
mehr anstecken das heißt alle die man
jetzt finden würde würden keine mehr
anstecken wenn sie in die selbst
isolierung gehen und idealerweise baut
man das dann aus und da gibt es
wunderbare berechnungen von dem michael
nein aber der epidemiologe der sagt
letztlich ist dass die strategie die uns
dann auch durch diese zeit bis zur
herdenimmunität bringen könnte wenn wir
regelmäßig zu hause tests machen und es
gibt welche die in entwicklung sind
deswegen aber hier streifen daran man
das ergebnis nach 20 sekunden helfen uns
die tests helfen aber die ich kenne
michael mine ganz gute kost kollege also
an der hand habe und was er vorschlägt
ist dass man es quasi also so oft testet
in den risikogruppen dass man unter die
reproduktions zeitkonto sie ist hier
vier tage das heißt ich muss quasi
zweimal pro woche testen wenn ich in
pflegeeinrichtungen zu einer pro woche
testet dann kann ich tatsächlich damit
ausbrüche in pflegeeinrichtungen mehr
oder weniger verhindert man muss sich
aber zweimal pro woche testen und so
schlägt marco mehner auch vor könnte man
in großen kapazitäten durch selbst test
die bevölkerung möglicherweise schützen
das sind aber zwei dinge zu beachten
eine einmalige testung hat diese wirkung
nicht die kann sogar nach hinten feiern
es hat zb in österreich überhaupt nichts
gebracht weil die leute die also dann
den test gemacht haben wir denken dann
okay jetzt nicht negativ jetzt also kann
mir nichts passieren
die party genau also das kann das muss
ich durchhalten können und wir haben bis
zum jahresende von dem was ich weiß ich
bin auch mit den herstellern in
verbindungen die jetzt sagen wir gut
nicht alle tests sind gleich gut also
der beste rechte ist das sind die beiden
besten
und wenn man die jetzt die tests aber
rein nimmt die noch in der größenordnung
sind da ich mich darauf verlassen kann
dann haben wir für das gesamte also
jahresende haben wir bis zum jahresende
noch 30 millionen test die brauchen wir
für die pflegeeinrichtungen ist dies
noch nichtmals in den schulen testen
wenn ich in eine pflegeeinrichtung
zweimal pro woche testen und testet dann
auch noch die besucher wenn ich das
machen oder sind die tests schon fast
weg wenn ich das jetzt also in einem
strohfeuer verbraucher in einer
einmaligen testung der bevölkerung wo
ich nur jedem zweiten testen könnte das
hielte ich will dann also sagen bin ich
nicht überzeugt das ist auf jeden fall
nicht die denkweise von mike romina daad
immer zu recht auf den habe ich schon
vor vielen monaten gewesen das hätte man
mit an und es auch machen kann mit
geburten pc aus sauber haben wir sogar
mal diskutiert mitgeboten pcs wäre das
vor den antigen test schon möglich
gewesen aber das ist so nicht
stattgefunden hätte hätte aber dann wird
es gemacht haben holten testen haben
jetzt auch nur kurze zeit also hallo
ganz andere pflegeheime durchwinken
würde wäre natürlich vor jedes
pflegeheim und für jedes altenheim auch
menschen zu stellen die dafür sorgen
dass besucher und bewohner getestet
werden